[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and keep watching
this video if you want to continue to
exist now throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the fifth
episode of agents of shield and
discussing everything you need to know
about the latest century obviously there
will be heavy spoilers here itself you
don't anything ruined and I highly
recommend that you turn off now please
drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the video
and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns on the show every
week without further adieu thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown okay so the fifth episode
picks up in 1973 with by far the best
intro ever soon as that theme tune and
the graphics started up
I was absolutely dying and the entire
entry follows this style with a pretty
much becoming a 70s cop drama I used to
love in TV shows when characters would
look at the camera and smile in the
intro and to do it here I just found it
absolutely hilarious by far the best
decade within the first minute of the
show it takes us to New York City and
here we watch the events of a trout in
the milk play out now it's not something
I've heard before today but the phrase a
trout in the milk means drawing
conclusions from circumstantial evidence
the trout in the milk sort of means that
the milks been watered down because the
dairy farmer was clearly dipping the
milk pail into a stream to add more
water to it and now you can't prove
that's what happened you can sort of
draw conclusions by there being the fish
in the liquid anyway we'll talk about
how this ties in to the episode later
but it is something you should bear in
mind with what happens the episode
starts off with Coulson very much taking
a trip down memory lane and he remembers
the stereotypical New York where taxi
drivers are constantly beeping their
horn and people shout hey I'm walking
here every five minutes Sousa is having
a bad time blending in and he starts to
contemplate that he may have always been
pulled out of time it's a theory that we
had last week and personally I side with
the idea that he was always plucked out
by the agents
King everything a perfect loop they go
to the swordfish bar from the first
episode and this time instead of someone
sliding open the door and asking for a
password you just type it into a code
panel it's a nice switcher that shows
just how far things have come including
Enoch who he learns been there for 40
years
he literally had one job err I know we
said that last week but it's still a
good joke and let's be honest this
there's not many of them on the channel
now back on borders effort Simmons
starts to tease that Fitz will be
appearing soon there's a theory that
when we catch up to him he's gonna be
much much older than everyone else but
as of yet we don't know Jemma also has
something on the back of a neck that
makes it seem like she might be in LMD
so yes we're back on that theory
I actually think it's something
different as the EMP area51 didn't
disable her but perhaps she is far more
advanced than the others are however
bear in mind that Simmons belt Coulson
using the same LMD technology so it
doesn't make sense that he would Shaw
out and she wouldn't again they might
just change the rules up and have things
be inconsistent but we'll see as we get
further into the show Jemma does
complain that she's getting forgetful
but we never quite find out what's going
on with her but yes the LMD theory is
indeed back elsewhere mack and yoyo go
to the lighthouse which is supposedly
meant to be abandoned due to Shield of
vacating it in 1972 Mack is trying to
make a move but yo-yo who always bounces
back is still having a hard time I'm
kind of getting a bit meh on the whole
her doubting herself as they're doing it
pretty much every week and I don't know
I'm just getting a bit tired of it now
before they can dwell on it too much
they discover that something in the
timeline has changed and people are
still in the facility which does add a
lot of intrigue to the show throughout
the episode they learn that it's a
launchpad for Hydra which plays into the
overall plot of the entry in the
speakeasy we learn that Enoch has been
missing for over a year and the agents
come across general Rick's stoner or
little Ricky for short if you recognize
his voice it's because he plays Joe in
Family Guy and he introduces Wilfred
Malik Malik should have died three years
prior however
The Chronicles have changed the timeline
we actually got a theory right that I
was quite surprised about and because of
the chronic comms project insight has
had a 40-year Head Start through
satellites instead of helicarriers Hydra
can now kill all those that could
potentially pose a threat to them I was
genuinely just throwing out one of the
big Hydra shield events last week as a
theory so was actually quite surprised
when it came true but actually makes a
lot of sense when you think about it
more this plan would completely decimate
shield and all that could oppose Hydra
leading to there being no way to stop
the chronic comms in the future we learn
that there's a target list which
includes some notable peoples such as
Peggy Carter star of the hit show agents
of Carter Nick Fury the director of
shield who of course formed the Avengers
Bruce Banner yet who you already know
Betty Wright a 70 cell singer and Jim
Morita who was one of the Howling
Commandos who's also Victoria Han on the
list who you might remember from the
other series of agents of shield and the
rest are political figures and activists
this is the titular trout in the milk
and though Coulson is unable to verify
that the chronic comms had anything to
do with it all the evidence points
towards it in the Winter Soldier the
names were compiled by an algorithm
created by Zola
however here they've been given by the
chronic comms who are of course aware of
future events may goes to make the moves
on stoner and we learned that though
they're close to launching project
insight it's still three years away we
also meet a younger Gideon Malick who
starts flirting with Daisy
this is obviously bad because it could
trigger her into killing him which she
seems to want to do to every character
in every episode however she changes her
mind and steps away after being helped
along by Sousa I'm definitely starting
to ship Sousa and Daisy and I really
held that the two end up together
because yeah the man deserves some
happiness Daisy and Sousa sneak into the
hidden room and the speakeasy that she
learned about in 1931 which is where
they discovered the list Coulson gets
made by Malick and the chronic comms
arrived but Daisy is able to get them
out of there by holding Nathaniel Malik
hostage in earlier seasons Nathaniel was
sacrificed to the hive however due to
the timeline changing he's still alive
and thus they're able to properly
threatened Wilfred Enoch arrives outside
and says which is of course a play on
the line that's been laced throughout
the Terminator franchise The Chronicles
realized that they're going to change
the timeline further and thus they carry
out another jump to 1976 which of course
forces the Zephyr to go there too as we
know this is the year that project
insight will launch and the group enact
their plan to infiltrate the base I love
the scene in which Daisy shows Souza how
her phone works and shortly after
Nathaniel arrives and knocks them out
with a stun gun Coulson and May enter
the lighthouse and yo-yo and deke go to
Malik's estate Malick has been visited
once more by the chronic comms and they
gave him a photograph of Max parents
will then have been taken hostage and
are now at the lighthouse in the
lighthouse
maeín Coulson try and talk stone out of
launching the satellites but may just
knocks him out when she realizes through
her empathy abilities that she can sense
it's not working it seems like the plan
is working now however Malick begins to
reveal that the chronic calms know
absolutely everything he cuts his speech
short by shooting him and he's able to
do this because Malick was meant to be
dead at this point
so it doesn't really matter however it
did matter to me as this guy has just
been a pest throughout the season so I'm
glad I'm glad that deke finally got to
take him out this is when the reveal of
max parents come and he orders an abort
on the mission in order to save them
clearly the Chronicles knew that he
would be the kind of character that
would do this and thus they chose his
parents and not the others project
insight must be stopped at all costs
though and thus they launched the Zephyr
and shoot down the rocket from the air
which reveals their position in the
stinger scene at the end of the episode
we see Nathanael inquiring about Daniel
Whitehall you may remember him from
earlier seasons and he was fascinated by
the Inhumans but Daniel clearly once
Daisy's powers and this ends the episode
on a big cliffhanger with him
potentially becoming a superhuman should
he get his wish now we will be talking
about the promo for episode 6 titled
adapt or die so if he don't anything
ruined then I highly recommend that you
turn off now
now from the looks of it after the
attack on the air shield and Hydra
launch countermeasures against the
Zephyr which will bring it crashing down
it also seems like the chronic comms
have been replacing all of the agents at
the lighthouse with their own and thus
their new plan is to take down shield by
sort of doing an invasion of the body
snatchers switcheroo
Coulson also comes face to face with the
big bad and it does look like we're
heading towards a cool episode next week
anyway that wraps up the latest sentry
and obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below and let me know if you enjoyed
this video then please drop a thumbs up
and if you missed our analysis of any of
the other episodes that make sure you
check them out after this you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat to us after
the show either follow us that heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below every month we
give away free movies to people our
subscribe to the channel and this Monty
can when the MCU infinitely Saga box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of July and the cell be shipped
out from the interval gets the prize
it's the best of luck to everyone who
takes part
you